no Alba English at all that's crazy
all right hold on
let's see
hey hold on
hola anybody speak English I don't speak
English all right cool cool um
all right
um this is our first date which I'm just
getting to know her and I was hoping
that you could help me out with a little
translation
please por favor sure why not
there's a few things I want to get to
know about her
she is she hoping for marriage again how
does she feel about that
maybe maybe oh I'm feeling worried
foreign
when was the last time you were with a
woman
uh sexually sexual Mentor say see all
right
it's been uh five months the last person
I was with and the last person I was in
love with it's been like two years now
and right now you're still in love are
you no I'm um but I'm open to Falling in
Love again
we can start with tonight
[Laughter]
so I'm the type of guy when things get
awkward I just get silly at that point I
just gotta go for it
how does she feel about me being a
polygamist with three other wives
okay
foreign
[Music]